l'inde plongée dans l'enfer de la
pandémie submergé par le nombre de
victimes
le pays tente de sortir la tête de l'eau
des hôpitaux de fortune
témoin de la détresse ambiante dans le
pays les files d'attentes pour obtenir
des bouteilles d'oxygène ne cesse quant
à elle de s'allonger dans certaines
villes la communauté internationale
réagit et se mobilisent face à cette
catastrophe sanitaire
la france et l'allemagne ont promis des
containers d'oxygène et dette médical
qui devrait arriver dans les prochains
jours les premières cargaisons de
matériel en provenance du royaume uni et
de la russie ont déjà été réceptionné
par les autorités indiennes
ce mercredi le secrétaire d'état
britannique chargé de l'asie a apporté
son soutien à la population indienne les
scènes déchirantes qui se sont déroulés
en inde ces derniers jours nous ont tous
choqués
la pandémie a entraîné d'horribles
souffrances humaines et nous adressons
notre solidarité et nos condoléances au
peuple indien en ces moments difficiles
je suis heureux que d'autres pays
répondent également aux besoins de
l'inde
la pandémie a montré l'importance d'une
action internationale
personne n'est en sécurité tant que tout
le monde de les parer nous continuerons
donc à travailler en étroite
collaboration avec le gouvernement
indien pour l'aider à relever l'énorme
défi auquel il est confronté et nous
continuerons à montrer notre solidarité
avec le peuple indien outre l'europe la
chine et les etats unis ont également
promis de venir en aide à l'inde
objectif accélérer la campagne de
vaccination afin de ralentir la
propagation du virus les autorités
américaines devraient fournir de la
matière première pour la fabrication de
vaccins
la russie quant à elle a prévu d'envoyer
une première cargaison de spoutnik vais
d'ici la fin de la semaine
lors d'un entretien téléphonique vadimir
poutine a promis aux premiers ministres
indien à rennes drame audi une aide
humanitaire d'urgence
la russie doit acheminer au total plus
de 22 tonnes de matériel en attendant
l'aide internationale la situation
demeure hors de contrôle dans les villes
les crématoriums à ciel ouvert se
multiplient
face aux nombreux décès difficile de
s'organiser ils attendent se fait longue
on tenir deux ou trois morts c'est à
dire que si on vient pour une
nous sommes arrivés ici vers 7 heures du
matin nous attendons toujours et on peut
voir environ 15 ambulances qui attendent
chacune d'entre elles pouvant contenir
deux ou trois morts c'est à dire que si
on vient pour une crémation
on doit attendre jusqu'à la fin de la
journée pour qu'elle soit terminée et
même à ce moment là ce n'est pas
forcément possible
j'ai entendu dire que 8 des ambulances
qui sont là-bas attendent depuis hier
soir
il ne s'agit pas seulement de moi c'est
plutôt que tout le monde est confronté à
ça
comme on peut le voir il ya un certain
nombre d'ambulances qui attendent là bas
ça prend plus de 24 heures ou même
quarante huit heures les gens attendent
encore
maintenant cela fait plus de vingt
quatre heures que j'attends le nombre
quotidien de décès ne cesse de grandir
jour après jour le seuil des 200 milles
morts a été franchi ce mardi plus de
3000 décès ont été déclarés en 24 heures
une première pour ce pays lourdement
touchés par le virus
des chiffres catastrophiques et qui
selon de nombreux experts pourrait être
largement sous-estimées